und jetzt das heute-journal
von mir und heinz wolf guten abend
natürlich leiden viele millionen in der
ukraine aber besonders das schicksal von
mario pohl bewegt das ganze land das
russische militär bombte die südliche
hafenstadt in schutt und asche und hält
sie nach wochenlanger belagerung
mittlerweile fast vollständig besetzt
mit ausnahme des stahlwerkes of style
heißes mehrere tausend soldaten und
zivilisten verschanzten sich dort harren
unter schlimmsten bedingungen aus unter
ihnen viele ältere und familien mit
kindern heute wenigstens die gute
nachricht vom beginn einer
evakuierungsaktion laut ukraine ist
präsident sie lenski konnten ca 100
menschen herausgebracht werden mehr von
dalian tag
und es gibt sie doch offenbar kleinen
zeichen der hoffnung unter
zusammenarbeit russischer und
ukrainischer soldaten sind diese
zivilisten entkommen aus den belagerten
stahlwerk in mario pohl in eine
provisorische aufnahme einrichtungen der
pro russischen region donetsk die
vereinbarte waffenruhe hat gehalten der
humanitären korridor nicht unter
beschuss eine evakuierungsaktion unter
federführung von un und rotem kreuz rund
100 menschen sollen es bislang so weit
geschafft haben für sie soll es nun
weiter in das ukrainische szabo reacher
gehen allein in den bunkeranlagen des
stahlwerks soll nach ukrainischen
angaben noch immer rund 1000 zivilisten
eingeschlossen seien andere bilder vom
russischen verteidigungsministerium
heute die odessa zeigen sollen russische
präzisions raketen hätten eine landebahn
und einen hunger mit waffen und munition
der usa und der europäischen länder
zerstört
die besatzer sammeln im osten des landes
zusätzliche kräfte für neue angriffe auf
unser militär
sie verstärken ihre truppen in der
region kharkiv um den druck auf den don
bass zu erhöhen sie haben mehr als
23.000 soldaten verloren in den kämpfen
in diesem sinnlosen krieg aber sie hören
nicht auf
hier sind die russischen truppen
abgezogen aus dem dorf co tiefgang in
rackith überlebende treffen lebensretter
journalisten auf augenzeugen
sie kamen in unsere wohnung sie nahm die
schlüssel und verbannten uns in den
keller wir lebten eineinhalb monate im
kalten keller mein mann ist sehr krank
er hatte einen herzinfarkt
der zehnjährige savelli am grab seines
vaters
er hat den krieg nicht überlebt ihr
pilot westlich von kiew ist es
totensonntag in der ukraine auch ihr
team wurde befreit zurück bleibt die
trauer und ohnmacht über einen krieg
denn nun 67 tage geht
sie wissen deutschland will ja so
schnell wie möglich unabhängig von
russischer energie werden aktuelle
zahlen von heute aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium belegen das ist
auch fortschritte gibt die abhängigkeit
von erdgas sinkt von 55 auf aktuell noch
35 prozent die von steinkohle von 50 auf
8 und die von erdöl von 35 auf 12
prozent
öl ist ein gutes stichwort die eu plant
in den nächsten tagen ein sechstes
sanktionspaket inklusive einfuhrstopp
für russisches erdöl da wollen wir
nachfragen bei florian hahn in brüssel
florian die eu plant also ein sechstes
sanktionspaket mit öl embargo das berlin
wie man hört unterstützen will wie ist
das zu stande gekommen anfänglich war
deutschland in der frage ja eher
zurückhaltend ja in der tat und mancher
in brüssel der reibt sich durchaus
verwundert die augen denn in der tat
hatte berlin in dieser krise vor allem
eine rolle übernommen und zwar die des
bremsers auch aufgrund eigener hohe
abhängigkeit von russischer energie aber
die zahlen die wir gerade gesehen haben
die zeigen ist ja berlin hat wochen
ganze arbeit geleistet und diese
abhängigkeit insbesondere beim öl
deutlich verringert und insofern macht
man jetzt offenbar den weg frei für ein
öl embargo deutsche diplomaten die
freuen sich dass sie erstmals hier seit
wochen sozusagen vor der welle stehen
und nicht wie sonst zuletzt immer nach
wochen das nachvollziehen müssen was
andere seit langem auch von deutschland
gefordert haben nun bedarf es ja fürs
verabschieden eines sanktionspaket ist
der berühmten eu einstimmigkeit und
deutschland ist ja nicht das einzige
land das bedenken hatte wie steht es
denn um die mehrheitsfähigkeit ja auch
da tut sich offenbar bemerkenswertes es
gab in der tat einige länder die jetzt
die rolle von deutschland übernommen
hatten sozusagen als bremser und hier
widerstand angemeldet hätten gehörten
etwa von spanien das stark steigende
energiepreise durch ein solches embargo
gefordert hatte oder von ländern wie der
slowakei und ungarn die selbst in hohem
maße abhängig sind von russischer
energie aber ein hochrangiger
eu-diplomat sagte mir heute abend dass
man jetzt nach intensiven gesprächen an
diesem wochenende nichts mehr mit einem
veto rechner insofern sei der weg
offenbar frei und zwar auch aufgrund des
beschränkten der deutschen
bundesregierung es gibt nur wie immer in
solchen dingen brüssel ein kleines aber
man ringt hier noch um übergangsfristen
von durchaus mehreren monaten die auch
berlin nach fordert insofern man könnte
dieses öl embargo in der nächsten woche
bereits beschließen in kraft treten aber
würde es wohl erst in ein paar monaten
danke für die information live aus
brüssel war dass florian a
der tag der arbeit der fällt in eine
zeit in der sich immer mehr menschen
immer weniger leisten können corona
krise ukraine krieg und rekord-inflation
treffen und verunsichern arbeitnehmer
enorm entsprechend groß die
zukunftsängste und entsprechend laut die
heute im heutigen forderungen nach
ausgleich aber auch die nach einer
absage an militärische aufrüstung
was dann auf einer kundgebung zu einem
brüllenden kanzler führte und wann hat
man olaf scholz jemals brüllen hören
über den tag der arbeit in kriegszeiten
berichtet jetzt stephan merseburger
gemeinsam die zukunft gestalten so das
motto des er mai in diesem jahr corona
ist noch immer nicht vorbei und es
herrscht krieg in europa tausende sind
so zentralen veranstaltungen in berlin
gekommen was bewegt sie inflation
steigende preise für energie
lebensmittel und mieten kaufkraftverlust
gerechtigkeit
ich bin heute mit dabei weil es mir
total wichtig ist dass wir irgendwie für
mehr lohn auf die straße gehen wir auch
gleiche bezahlung gerade als frau muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen wir haben noch
einen lohn ungleichgewicht und manchmal
wünsche ich mir auch mehr freizeit
klimakrise
wirtschaftskrise und gleichzeitig waren
die reichen immer reicher
aldi macht milliarden in unserer
gesellschaft ist wahnsinnig ungerecht
das wurde auch auf der kundgebung in
mainz beklagt der verdi chef will die
superreichen und reichen für das
allgemeinwohl zur kasse bitten durch
eine abgabe auf hohe vermögen durch eine
angemessene besteuerung von hohen
erbschaften und kapitaleinkünften und
durch eine international wirksame
besteuerung von unternehmensgewinnen das
wäre gerecht und dass es auch überfällig
der krieg in der ukraine war überall
thema die ebenso beherrschende wie
zwiespältige frage kann man krieg
fördern und gleichzeitig waffen liefern
das finde ich ist ein total ist lärm auf
jeden fall ja
aber ich denke wenn wir nichts tun
überlassen
das finde ich auch nicht gut der
dgb-vorsitzende hofmann warnte vor einer
dauerhaften aufstockung des
rüstungsetats das binde zu viel geld
wir brauchen es für die
leistungsfähigkeit unseres sozialstaates
militärische sicherung darf niemals
auf kosten sozialer unsicherheit
erkauft werden auf der veranstaltung in
düsseldorf trat der bundeskanzler auf
die lautstarken proteste gegen die
lieferungen schwerer waffen am kiew
konnte schulz zu
lassen
selten womöglich nie hat man olaf scholz
so erlebt es
einen bürger der ukraine schönes
vorkommt wenn gesagt wird er solle sich
gegen die position ohne waffen
verteidigen was ist aus der zeit
gefallen ein tag der arbeit überlagert
vom krieg die menschen wollten ein
zeichen setzen für gerechtigkeit
demokratie und frieden
bei uns jetzt weiter mit weiteren
nachrichten mit heinz und es gab ja noch
zahlreiche andere demonstration heute ja
so ist am abend ein demonstrationszug
mit mehreren tausend teilnehmern durch
berlin gezogen linke und linksradikale
gruppen hatten zu dem protest aufgerufen
der zug begann in neukölln und endete in
kreuzberg die polizei war mit einem
großaufgebot im einsatz und bis zur
stunde wurden keine größeren
zwischenfälle gemeldet
die usa haben der ukraine weitere
unterstützung zugesichert die
vorsitzende des us repräsentantenhauses
nancy pelosi war überraschend zu einem
besuch in kiew zu einem treffen mit
präsident zielinski sie sagte wir
befinden uns an einer grenze der
freiheit und ihr kampf ist ein kampf für
alle deshalb ist es unsere verpflichtung
für sie da zu sein bis der kampf beendet
ist
auch in der türkischen metropole
istanbul wurde anlässlich des ersten mal
demonstriert dabei kam es zu
zusammenstößen mit der polizei die
beamten nahmen nach eigenen angaben mehr
als 160 menschen fest sie hatten
versucht zum taksim platz zu gelangen
dort hatten 2013 die
regierungskritischen proteste begonnen
der platz ist seitdem für mai demos
gesperrt
später als andere europäische länder
hebt italien fast alle corona bedingten
beschränkungen ab heute auf der so
genannte grüne pass muss nur noch in
wenigen fällen vorgezeigt werden er
weist den impf beziehungsweise genesenen
oder test status nach gelockert wird
auch die masken pflicht in bars und
restaurants ist kein schutz mehr
notwendig jedoch weiterhin etwa in kinos
und öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln nach
den crooner bedingten absagen tausender
veranstaltungen in den letzten zwei
jahren ist der kultur hunger riesengroß
weswegen konzerte theater kino kunst
jetzt logischerweise wieder boomen und
eine kunstform die zuletzt immer salon
und ausstellungs fähiger wurde ist open
art also im weitesten sinne kunst im
öffentlichen raum das reicht von
graffiti bis hin zu installationen mit
allem was die umgebung her gibt eine
ganz besondere umgebung ist das
weltkulturerbe völklinger hütte ein
riesengroßes eisenberg das
1986 seinen betrieb einstellte und dort
begann heute die sechste senat biennale
susanne freitag nimmt uns mit
originalton und
[Musik]
original zugfenster aus frankreich sie
sind zu kunstwerken geworden
illegal übrigens sie stammen von diesem
geheim gehaltenen ort wo ausgesonderte
regionalzüge auf ihre verschrottung
warten
[Musik]
maxim drohe hat die fenster vor ort
besprüht sie dann ausgebaut und das darf
er eigentlich nicht in der völklinger
hütte sind sie jetzt ein highlight der
erben art biennale
ich habe immer ein damoklesschwert über
mir
das ist sehr kompliziert irgendwie habe
ich immer ein bisschen angst aber es ist
ja nicht unmoralisch es ist kunst es ist
vielleicht illegal aber nicht
die hütten arbeiter von heute sind
künstler waren riesen botschaften auf
die rostige ruinen
stoppt die kriegsmaschine steht auf dem
dach hello world hölle auf erden an der
wand drinnen baut street legende mick
rock aus holland ihr neues werk auf
diese stelle so eine art fabrik das ist
die ultimaten
spielplatz für graffiti maler
nicht nur in der hütte sondern erstmals
auch in der völklinger innenstadt über
alert
die arbeiterstadt soll aufgewertet
werden
unübersehbar das 600 quadratmeter große
porträt an der fassade der saarstahl
es zeigt ihn kaya urhahn einen der
vielen gastarbeiter aus der türkei die
auf der hütte arbeitet
1986 legte er zum letzten mal den
schalter am hochofen drei um dann machte
das werk dicht
heute fühlt er sich geehrt es fehlen
fast die worte sagt er uns denn er ist
das gesicht der stahlarbeiter geworden
kunst sei dank
russland ukraine
war die erben art politisch ein
algorithmus beschießen polizei
mit lebensmittelfarbe
im visier der künstler die welt von
heute
verstörend aktuell
die in art biennale in der völklinger
hütte noch bis november und jetzt
nochmal heinz mit weiteren nachrichten
für den deutschen judo-bund gab es am
schlusstag der europameisterschaft in
sofia zwei medaillen alina böhm gewannen
gold und johannes frey holte mit platz
zwei hinter dem niederländer jos geukers
759 ausgabe des deutschen radklassiker
eschborn-frankfurt davor der ire sam
bennett nach 183 kilometern im
massenspurt vor der alten oper als
erster über die ziellinie bester
deutscher wurde phil bauhaus als vierter
und drei wochen vor beginn der french
open hat das deutsche tennis doppel
kevin krawietz und andreas mies das
tennisturnier in münchen gewonnen mit
einem sieg im finale gegen ein
brasilianisch spanisches du in drei
sätzen
und auch die wetteraussichten zum start
in die neue woche morgen in der mitte
und im süden nach oft freundlichen
beginn einzelne schauer und gewitter
sonst wechselnd bewölkt und meist
trocken höchstwerte 13 bis 20 grad die
weiteren aussichten wenig änderungen bei
einer mischung aus sonne und wolken vor
allem im süden teils kräftige schauer
und gewitter höchsttemperaturen zwischen
12 und 20 grad
mit diesen mai aussichten verabschieden
wir uns für heute morgen begrüßt ihr
dann hier wieder christian sievers und
um 0.15 gibt es die nächste express dann
noch einen schönen sonntagabend für sie
wieder sinn
[Musik]